lawn order svu star mariska hargitay
stopped by the drew bearmore show and
gushed all about her husband of 17 years
peter herman
oh this story marishka looked back on
her first date with peter and admitted
she started crying because she realized
she met her husband in that very moment
it's not even real morgan i i here it is
okay
bye everyone hi
what was your first encounter with him
like was it love at first sight was
there a spark what because he's a real
presence he is and i was nervous
and i heard he was german
and i didn't know what to do
and so i said so oh this is so
embarrassing
i said so you're a crowd
it goes like this
that's funny
then i went
oh my god and then chris maloney's like
he's so funny and so different than
anyone i've i've ever met and we had
such a sort of beautiful um
getting to know each other and learning
how to
see each other and beautiful courtship
and
here we are you know 17 years married 19
years in
and you know still learning about each
other every day but like on that first
day okay are you like because you know
you're at work also i on the first day i
was so so nervous and i felt very he was
very handsome and it was uh distracting
and then he would come back the other
days and the all the producers would
look at me and go
and give me like eyes and stuff did they
know could they tell yeah yeah i'd never
been like that to anyone
to anyone ever wait do you know where
our first date was uh no tell me please
it's a little too good to be true
our first date he asked me to go to
church with him
yeah
and i was moving and i said peter i i
would love to but not today i'm moving
today and he goes oh come on it's an
hour it's an hour and it was so funny
and i just couldn't resist so i went to
church and it was that day i remember we
went to church and i had this little
daisy flower necklace and this it was
june 2nd
and i'm crying and he thinks that i'm so
moved by the sermon right and i'm crying
because i'm like i know i'm gonna marry
him
i found my husband i love him